take it away honestly
i'm smart what i call it smart a
combination of smart and shrewd
i don't like the shack and it's my
shtick that's fine i'm schtick i'm here
for you whitney i'm here to break up dog
fights i'm here to
watch you go to the bathroom i'm here to
eat greek food i am here teach me about
greek food this has been a whirlwind
since i've been here i mean let's just
there's dogs everywhere there's girls
everywhere i don't know who anyone is
i'm learning a lot of names so this is
the puppy for those of you not watching
listening um he's been posted i just
wanted the viewers to see this boy look
at his little liquid death toy that's
his logo yeah he's starting a podcast
soon starting a podcast soon it's called
who let the dogs out who let's dog and
then he drinks his june shine and then
just so everyone can see who we're
talking about because giannis is about
to tell a story about how he saved my
life last night and uh two of my dogs
went at each other over the puppy and
just you can't have two
two alphas there's too many alphas in
the kitchen i'm a stigma i'm a stigma
male
okay so there's alpha beta omega
sigma but you were calling it what does
a sigma do sigma males are more
independent they're kind of more so
acting
we can pretend you don't have to say you
did that we'll just redo it okay let's
redo it
you want to act it out should we get the
dogs back in here are you going to want
to put on makeup i am putting makeup on
thank you i think she looks great no i'm
it's right here i just don't make noise
do i need makeup um and then do we want
the female break half the poster in the
shot i think it's fine for now
i'd love to just have giannis hold up
the whole show in front of his face as
you can tell we're redoing the podcast
studio and we're putting all of the
things the fan art the the stuff that
you guys made brought me after shows
it's just special stuff in my life i
mean someone made a lego out of us i put
it in my ass last night i'm so afraid
grab that horse behind you i slept right
next door to your left left up where
that's me on like fans make this stuff
wait this is you from like a year this
is what pink hair so this is recent yeah
yeah all this is that's ludo from
labyrinth well this is actually
multi-colored hair this is your joker
face well that's those are my pubes yeah
my joker you mean my favorite well i
joke her face you mean my face no you
look like you're mrs joke you're looking
married to joker
i mean well i wouldn't marry an inferior
comedian to me so that's not true that's
true i would have taken sam morale and
uh who else is in that he's a good joker
writer yeah so ricky velez you love
ricky velasquez
but we're here to talk about you we're
going to tell these stories as if you
don't have to go whitney already told me
just tell it about what happened well
this is the funnest time to be a
comedian because
now that technology has enabled
comedians to just call the shots
this is how things happen yes yeah i
just woke up i slept next door patrick i
did another show inside i broke up a dog
fight so start now we're doing another
show uh-huh yeah and you're putting
makeup while the show's happening this
is what happens when comedians call the
show okay so listen and women because
the reason women haven't gotten to catch
up with you because we have less time
because you guys debilitated us to make
us insecure so now i've just spent two
hours in hair and makeup just to start
those two hours i could have shot two
more shows so i'm not gonna let putting
makeup on like eat into my time right
right you know what i mean so i'm just
but but this
is sitting in the room so holding a dog
this is going to be traumatic for her
but we're going to do it for when gg
gorge is coming i'm not leaving this
house to like watch you give birth to a
dog okay i know it's possible thank you
for thinking i'm fertile um so okay
giannis comes over yesterday
meets nick
okay him they're immediately talking
about i love nick the epigenetic
imprinting of boston and coaches and
governors that were elected in boston
that were mafia like explain who nick is
nick curzon my
littlest idi
my nick my whatever best friend told me
real brother real biological brother but
chosen and so
nick is works with me on my specials he
produces my specials like he's my like
larry david or maybe i'm larry david i
can't tell but um so yeah why is it
gonna be a man why do you gotta compare
yourself to men maybe you're you're
you're whitney coming okay but coming
cummings so he just learned last night
that my parents i don't know you i'm
learning who you are before before they
got married my dad's name was eric
cummings and my mom was patti cumming
right and then he's coming and they got
married and it was patti cumming
cummings so then i got made fun of come
shot i mean i would get papers back like
tests
and like you'd get the grade a minus my
bra size at the time
and
it would just
students like would have crossed out
cummings and just written shot gum shot
come fake like it was just like
and then um so i was like oh when they
got divorced i was like i'll take my
mom's name and it's coming
but that's the verb not the noun
comments is always better right right
who cares uh and so you come over
nick is coming over to watch the
football game and he never changes a lot
of coming going on yeah
i came over actually nobody came the
irony is not yeah there's no coming my
dude he's so busy stitching my animals
together i'd like
yeah i could have gotten i'm literally
should i get vaginal rejuvenation just
in the amount of time that there's no
chance for him to fuck me in what if he
doesn't notice apparently the worst part
is the catheter so
look up jane marie vaginal rejuvenation
get on it now i think it was on jezebel
yeah so you um
come over
have you had coffee yet i just want to
make sure because you seem kind of
low energy i
by the way off after all i mean i was on
five milligrams this is all natural
right now
it's adrenaline and like what what
office are you gonna walk into like this
and uh somebody's gonna prescribe you
adderall no i got prescribed adderall to
sleep so i can focus on sleeping to fall
asleep so because you are walking
adderall you know what i'm not taking
though no i just have been ready for
this moment you're fucking ready i'm
ready for this moment too this is bigger
than us this moment's bigger than that
this is a racehorse that has
wasn't i let me in coach i'm fucking
ready and i they didn't let me in they
did now it's now that
were the the game and like now that
there's no gatekeepers and red velvet
rope people the outsiders now i like
i've been ready right and i know i only
have like a year until someone finds an
old tweet that doesn't hold up yeah so
this i gotta i gotta i got like a year
and a half two years i've been borrowed
it's only gonna be a tweet with you well
no i did delete my tweets but no i mean
i have
i
i have could be video footage well it
could be it could be uh rolled roast
jokes yeah i started from the roasts
yeah joan's vagina is so old her pussy
has a separate entrance for black cocks
you can find it right now
is that your joke yeah that's a damn
good joke that was that's very funny
that was in the thing yeah i think i
just didn't know that um but that
because you know nothing about me and
like when you just
decide to google me so look last time i
was here i didn't even get a chair jonas
comes over nick lets me he never lets me
watch football with him ever well you
barely let us watch football
you had a lot to say we had to pause it
a lot
we actually didn't watch it when it
happened we had to pause it and you went
and then you'd give a moment
i mean your mouth went
and then we would did i say go up and
get the ball gag
table yeah if you can go get it if you
can find it if we can find it we could
do it i did have to jam like socks in my
mouth stop talking because the i was so
excited because the kansas city
hyenas game yeah you're not calling the
chiefs anymore they
it's just time it's this is this it's
just time that's all i covered is
chief's offensive though because it's
the top guy but not all native americans
have chiefs chiefs first of all right
and it's just you're benefiting from all
of that right so the chiefs regal
leaders
that i mean
the fucking chant is like whoa
like the chan is kind they do like yeah
the braves do the job but all the money
you're making on the jerseys just me i'm
not making it they just need to go clear
yeah uh uh is uh
needs to go to the native americans
indian reservations and getting them
fucking health care and their disaster
relations right now we're gonna just do
you know what i mean at least let the
native american women be cheerleaders
like something right you know i'll watch
that game know what
let in actual indian chiefs play i want
to watch that game right
right actual india like the team was
actual indians actual indians so um
love it that's my podcast yeah yeah are
we on it now i don't know what's going
on
are we switching back and forth between
you so we're watching this football game
be honest i know that you're like a
history sports cuff uh buff
but
but has a what's the name of your sports
podcast unleashed
unleashed not by by ronald and the other
one because i made it on unleashed where
we did comedy sitting down in front of a
shark tank with a little shark in it was
this show called unleash comics comics
comics
that's what i loved about that show was
organic we called it
comics yeah well the best was when uh
seth meyers i was at a coffee bean once
with neil brennan and seth meyers and
there was a pitch going around to snl
you might have been working there at the
time emily where they wanted to do uh a
sketch that was based on comics
unleashed because the way that they
would do it is you would give them the
material by the way byron allen we stan
byron allen is who mentored me and i
have everything he's got like a billion
dollars he bought the weather channel in
cash yeah uh at mitsy moore shores
memorial like on his phone um he bought
the i think he thought he was buying the
weather but he bought the weather
channel um he's like oh i thought the
jews aren't ready to sell the weather
yet
that they took from the native americans
yeah they're it's just they it's one
thing they want to keep so keep me on
track so you come over i never get to
watch football with nick he doesn't let
me because i can't stop running my
fucking whore mouth
and
i realize that i'm stumbling into one of
the greatest games of all time it was
yeah it was definitely one of the
greatest games of all time
we watched it after just give me a two
sentence thing they go into uh what
happened today was incredible two
seconds two sentences
13 seconds left tied the game one in
overtime crazy two that was two sets
crazy so i have worked i have video of
giannis watching it and i could tell by
his face like
we're witnessing something some
greatness here it was incredible what's
happening honestly this is one of the
greatest television insane what's
happening real-time females
what just happened the bills just scored
a touchdown with 13 seconds left
buffalo has a reason to not kill
themselves
because
in that city this is all they have
this is all they have in buffalo niagara
falls no they have um they have the
general mills and whoever is at the
club there that's it
oh my god
what is going on what is going on what
the fuck
this game is demanding he is
why are these guys so open and then when
there was it was on the fence and uh
ambiguous who was gonna win mm-hmm
we bet
we bet and we won a lot of money no no
no
no no i don't know where you're going
with this do it with bitcoin now bitcoin
can we start bitcoin we can start
bitcoin though just better
how about whitney coin
no because that is what um uh
sinclair oil and oil companies used to
do you couldn't build wealth because
they would basically pay the miners in
vouchers for the sinclair oil store so i
don't want i don't want whitney dollars
if it's only for stuff i sell well why
don't you just tell the people that
bitcoin that tulips were the original
bitcoin well no here's the other thing
we let you guys invent a value system
and you failed you guys chose wealth to
be based on gold so i think you guys as
men whatever your ancestor you didn't
yeah you were honest you were fucking
increased
that's right sorry sorry you're right
yeah so the the i don't have anything to
do with any of this but you know what
i'm saying okay i'm saying you guys
you're in west virginia you probably got
some some weird stuff in your house well
i i
mostly drank uh dupont teflon water so
it's just it's brain damage it's my cte
so whoever invented the bank system i
hate saying like straight cis men that's
not fair but basing on gold something
you can't eat or build with right and
something that only has value that we
trained women to want it right
well you got a lot of it now and then
well and then you decided okay there's
going to be these buildings these banks
that has a bunch of gold
in the closet and yet the people working
at the front are making ten dollars an
hour i just don't like any of it and
then you guys decided the next currency
was basically you guys you know what i
mean but you're but like why don't why
are you thinking about
those guys i'm on your side i know you
are yes i know you're with you i'm ready
for this revolution while you're in here
that's why you're in here i'm your first
captain you're in this room
you get to you get to grandmother you
get to stay yeah so this is the same as
yes
if coal mining and oil is going to be
replaced we have to make sure the coal
miners and the oil people have trades
to have jobs
bless you what happened he pee on you
sneezed not yet
oh sneeze little puppy so um so then the
next form of currency and value they
decided was baseball cards
yeah that's so nice forgive me if and
then the banks that you guys that they
made um
uh
charged me to be poor
right so if i overdraft seven dollars
you're charging me sixty dollars right
you're charging me to be poor now i can
never get out of it it just makes
everyone a debt in debt kind of it's
like an enslaving system yeah
and if we all took our money out of the
same time they'd be behooked we should
make something that has value inherent
values water should be based on water
jason momoa's hair strands
by the way
biggest career achievement through my
phone dave girl texted me an article
where
the jason momoa
story
um
of being breaking up or whatever the
divorce with lisa bonet
so when i got engaged before
jason momoa which time
one time
how dare you
so
one time this is okay so this is why the
robots are not going to take over and we
don't have to worry about it
not yet not yet so this is what the
article
came up
so there was a
um story i told about how when i got
proposed to jason mamoa was is across
the street like from the farm that i got
and he was like working out
and there was a guy who was secretly
taking photos of the engagement um my
ex's friend and jason momoa was working
out on the street and thought it was a
paparazzi because he was hiding in the
bushes
so it was a guy that was hiding in the
bushes to take photos of me
for my proposal and jason moe's like hey
man what are you doing and he was like
like if jason momoa does you're like i'm
gonna get the fuck out of here yeah and
so i almost didn't get my engagement
photos or like we didn't we didn't get
it the first time because he was too
afraid and then we had to restage them
so
then there's an article that comes out
this is just a habit show that too but
look at the photos
marriage is more bizarre than you
thought but it's me and him
oh that's you
the hair color is different it's tough
that is your this is when you were burnt
out stop the show right now if you need
to google me do you need to five minutes
no i know who you are so obviously a
russian bot wrote this article you look
great there too thank you i'm going back
to brown here tonight but tonight did
they just go in the algorithm it was
like whitney engagement like why is that
lisa bonnet or do i just look like i
have dreadlocks do i look like what why
did they do this
i don't know that's a good question yeah
robot didn't yeah robot did it they
don't they were not there yet with the
robots yes so we watched the greatest
game of all time we ordered the most
incredible greek food from
a tour of your library which is actually
incredible i love it it's not a lot it's
more of a sitting room with books it's a
it's a vintage book collect what would
you call that required reading for the
greats now are we going to go down there
and chill after this and have moments
for us because that was the whole point
of that room because you said this is
what you said to me you said we spend
too much time making content content
content everything's filmed comedians
need to just go sit
no characters i didn't say it then read
all those books i didn't say that
inarticulately
i think i was more elegant and sad the
reason i definitely said it quicker and
mormatically is there a sec
i don't know if it was more ticklish
definitely more manic how is it that i
have botox and my muscles are frozen and
i still talk faster than you
um drugs
i am on actually i went off prozac
because
grace is my kansas city chief of staff
you know grace is from kansas city so i
say there's a lot of people here i'm
trying to remember who's who we switched
pharmacies there was like three
construction workers in my room this
morning
they were building my bed as i was
sleeping
um and i think there's two dogs here
that you don't know about what do you
think cleopatra's house looked like yeah
there were a lot of people running
around doing shit i needed this i'm a
boring married man and i've been in a
fun house
and so i know this is also based on pbs
playoffs i love this i love this this is
based on peewee's playhouse i think he
just made that up i know i grew up on so
no it's based on the kitchen from weird
science oh is it and then that's where
it's science it's not pee-wee's
playhouse but
you gotta pick one whitney but no i
don't know
that's that's that's where you're wrong
two things can be true we can be
inspired by multiple things joan rivers
and george carlin and rodney dangerfield
and then we because we can't duplicate
other people we have to
take what we like and leave the restroom
everyone so weird science is part of the
inspiration and then all the toy because
i was like can i do a package that just
has fucking tchotchkes everywhere does
that look dumb and crazy i was like wait
no
let's be mr rogers um so let's get back
to this because i i just feel like
emily's just aging we're aging her uh
necessarily no it can't be worse than
that
so then we're having this best the best
time
uh watching this game we ordered an
incredible greek meal you ordered
the restaurant
you didn't order the meal you just said
bring what you have
the amount of food that came last night
i was like whitney are you expecting
more people is there any left
is there any left i'm sure
i'm sure i don't want i want to know if
the restaurant is still in here
they have no more inventory alex came
home from an emergency surgery my man he
came home right at the right moment when
he we we almost needed to do emergency
surgery on animals the timing when you
do the work
god does the rest or the universe
whatever you think and so
um
what a night is what you're saying
nobody had quite a night firehouse
taverna authentic greek cuisine
yanez thought told me what to order
taught me the words have this incredible
meal
during the meal i did need to do a
little dog training you did you do a
little dog training yes you did a little
dog training during the meal she got up
from supper we were having supper
and uh in her in her dining room there's
a door that leads right outside and she
we have a new little puppy here we don't
12 weeks still it should be with his mom
learning from his mom he's a cutest
little puppy we have a name to me
breeder dropped him off uh he had parvo
a horrible pit bull breeder who breeds
like ferraris dogs like these dogs are
um
bred to fight had parvo had already cut
his ears and took it to the vet where my
uh boyfriend works and said um well he
runs the fucking place i need to choose
my words i love your boyfriend and you
were talking all night his kid is smart
kid is smart humbling and and a good
looking kid can do the new york and i
like his haircut it looks like someone
just put a bowl over his head and cut
the sides peeky blinders yeah oh peeky
miners when he allows me to like so i
will get there and i'm not gonna force
it but i just want bald with a beard so
when he's ready
you want to shave it all off i just want
bald with a beard that's my shit
buzz cut with a beard navy seals only
okay you know what i'm saying well he
doesn't like i don't think he's ever
gonna get like you and theo you guys got
to stop with the hair transplants we
want you bald
[Laughter]
this is all natural by the way i know
yeah fucking you and stamos yeah go to
the same guy i know well no i go to my
mother-in-law i think he has a team but
but it's we're scooping him forward a
little bit what happens when you scoop
it back it's you know i'm here you know
what
that's it's moving forward it's receding
forward yeah no it's yeah i got a good
hair so we um so i go out
so training puppies i'm trying to put as
much of it on my instagram right now but
just guys be patient with me as i edit a
video together training puppies is one
of the hardest things for people if you
don't have the time do not get a puppy
um you should come out with your own
book on how to do it because i've never
seen someone do it as hands-on as you do
it you get in there you mean as quickly
you become a dog so you are the you were
the dog's mother and so during dinner
she said hold up one second i did the
puppy's got to go out to pee and then
whitney went outside
and she peed with the puppy well no i
peed and you peed to show the puppy yeah
you peed too
pee
how to pee so she squatted down and i
said to nick nick was sitting there and
nick goes she goes i'm going to go out
there and pee with the show show the
puppy that to pee and i'm going to pee
first and nick goes i don't think you
have to do that and then he's going i
don't think he'd do that and my back is
suit and i went is she peeing and nick
goes he went
yeah he goes like this yeah she's pinned
and so i just turned around real quick
and yeah whitney was peeing
and showing the dog how to pee
you also told me that you like to
sometimes pee just to sort of mark the
territory for the coyotes so let you let
them you let the coyotes know that this
is your territory that so if they do you
ever shit
in corners of your property well what
did i do when we saw that shit on the
ground last night you picked it up with
your hand and i don't think you washed
your hand till after the dog fight well
what i do is i so in my
so what you missed this morning so he
the dog started peeing so i slid into
first base yeah got the poop as it was
coming out
emily from before when emily i caught
some and she just quit have you has that
does she have you ever watched her train
the dog how to pee
when she piece emily's writing her um is
looking for other jobs so i picked up
the um
poop and i just throw it over the fence
so they know this well you have to walk
it down a long way you held that pool in
your hand for a long time and before you
walked it down to throw it over the
fence
you were talking to me for a
like a couple minutes and i said whitney
you know like because you were waving
the pool around it was in your head you
were telling me about why it's the
easiest way to pick a poo is just and i
was you were like you're not going to
waste you said i'm not going to waste
the napkin on this this is the quickest
way to do it and it's the least because
when you take a pick up shit with a
napkin you jam it into the right so that
was the way you wait for it to dry just
give it two hours and you just pick up
with your hands
yeah and then last night remember there
was one in there and i just put it down
the toilet yes that was another way you
could do it yeah so then we're having
this amazing night
were like
here's the book shot like bob sage
passed away like we lost louis anderson
like we now need to step up and be the
leaders and we're uniquely designed for
it okay you greet god yeah you have
experience with fucking animals pit
bulls like you've done the work and
you're at your ascension like we're the
rodney danger fields like we need to be
leaders and i'm like and then and then
we're talking about the the library
we're going to sit around and read the
books of the greats and learn and
because we need to do our homework your
history hyenas so you know more but i
need to study study up right because the
history books i read have all been
debunked i don't know anything and so my
dad uh uh eric cummings like he would
this is where i come from
so everyone who's like whitney and her
hot takes and her dad like she's
like
that's your emotional reaction to me i
get it it's not my job to be liked it's
my job to be neutral and defend both
sides right right it should feel
dangerous and you should we should do
that i think we shouldn't be left or
right we should be comedians you'll
you'll in three years you'll go i know
what she was trying to say right i know
where she was going with that even if i
don't do it perfectly you're like the
kanye west of comedy
benton yeah would you like to say
something yeah i would love to say that
it's time to take a break from y'all
the people that people need to
hear something else they need to
unclench their butt cheeks and they need
to learn about you know the importance
of manscaping they need a break from
winsting i like manscape but i've been
watching a lot of cheer
and so i did write a cheer about man's
favorite cheers
really
we could really pump this up okay so who
am i
um jerry you're on you're not a man
you're not on the mat so if you could
just cheer from the sideline okay the
chair trim your weenie trim your chest
and you will get to see more breaths
yes
i am so impressed that i'm speechless
that's not good mad talk when have i
ever been speechless
it's never happened well valentine's day
is coming up and we know just the gift
for you to give that special someone for
and all special occasions this
valentine's day it's time to give him a
gift that four million men worldwide
trust from manscape valentine's day is
gonna happen whether you like it or not
we can do it the easy way or the hard
way right everything that you want to
complain about is gonna happen
regardless let's just make it as smooth
as possible if you put on this fragrance
you'll do it the hard way manscaped is
the leader in below waist grooming use
whitney's exclusive offer go to
manscape.com and use code whitney for 20
off and free shipping treat him and
yourself to the formulations that will
have him smelling good
even if you
lost your sense of smell due to covet it
smells good i spray it on my body pillow
also make sure his body also smells good
with their signature scent the manscaped
refined cologne to complement his
collection featuring a light citrus
burst that settles with anchoring notes
of vetiver and a woodsy masculine finish
manscaped created products that they're
actually going to use after valentine's
day go to mancake.com for our exclusive
offer of 20 off plus free shipping with
the code whitney get 20 off and free
shipping with the code
whitneymanscape.com that's 20 off with
free shipping at manscape.com and use
code whitney gift cupid and arrow from
manscaped this valentine's day
boner joke
so
i know what you're thinking
i'm psychic call me now for your free
reading
what you're thinking i know what your
dad's thinking i know what your mom's
thinking and if you don't know i'll tell
you we're going to talk about athletic
greens guys this is our next sponsor
you're thinking
how did these people get all this energy
what powers this team of mental athletes
not physical at all uh mental health i
have a sleeping drug the body of a
weightlifter baby
our next partner has a product that
whitney uses literally every day and so
do i because she has a lot of it at her
house when you think mental clarity you
think whitney cummings
you think
alertness whitney coming focus
whitney cummings
staying on topic not interrupting mental
clarity whitney cummings and that's
because of athletic greens it supports
mental clarity and alertness
tons of people take some kind of
multivitamin it's important to choose
one with high quality ingredients that
your body will actually absorb no point
in taking it if your body doesn't absorb
it and to be clear you do have to
actually ingest the athletic grains you
can't just pour it on the floor and roll
around and it doesn't absorb that way
you're investing in an all-in-one
nutritional insurance right now it's
time to reclaim your health and arm your
immune system with convenient daily
nutrition especially heading into cold
and flu season to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune supporting
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase all you have to
do is visit
it athletic greens.com
whitney a year supply again that is
athleticgreens.com
whitney to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance and i know you're
thinking how do i see more of this and
in person well carolina theater fret not
we're going to be in durham at the
carolina theater in north carolina
on the 29th of this month february 3rd
will be in charlotte north carolina
another city in the same state at the
canite theater february 4th will be in
charleston south carolina
at the charleston music hall peddling
our wares and dazzling the masses
february 5th will be in wilmington
delaware at the grund opera house we get
it it's grand it's in wilmington that's
obvious oh so shitty ocean city here i
come from
lost my virginity outside the grottoes
february 10th cincinnati
ohio taft theater
see you there february 1 19th february
11th bethlehem pennsylvania is that a
religion
the wind creek event wind creek event
center at the fart center ceremony the
wind creek event
it's an event it's an event center but
it's also an event i it's called the
wind creek event center
so
we are doing uh this like
we're going to start a podcast together
called book club we are me you couple
people we cliff notes i think we started
about 14 podcasts yesterday we started a
couple businesses yeah we did we started
a couple businesses yeah and um and so
then
i'm trying to get the order of the new
puppy because mona's the alpha
uh frank is the beta daisy's the omega
and like integrating a new puppy is very
complicated especially if you have
powerful dogs
janna says he's a
sigma male and what is that exactly uh
an independent male kind of
is his own kind of away from the pack
wanders alone hunts alone but he kind of
can still pop in and out and breed and
can take care of himself yeah he still
comes in you know flirts with a couple
of the children if someone needs him
he'll he'll he'll he doesn't care about
the pack he just if it's worth it yeah
the allegiance will come in if you need
me i'm there like i was for you last
night yes you're the stigma i was there
yeah stick i'm the stigma male the
stigma
um
so i thought you were getting attacked
by a mountain lion that's what it
sounded like that that day's coming i
didn't know what was going on and you
know mountain lion bring it on because i
need something to fuck up my face in
like two years so i haven't experienced
left that ever makes the news that
whitney got into a fight with a mountain
lion i i
you could win that fight
you've been practicing you've been
peeing on floors you've you've been
shitting on the ground
you're ready you know how you win a
fight with the mountain lion shit at it
you don't play the only way to win is to
not play you give it space it wants
nothing to do with you we don't taste
good maybe if i'm on my period they'll
sniff twice but they if you get eaten by
a mountain lion or bitten by a
rattlesnake it is your fault will papa
pop work if they come pop up
which do your fans know that that that
is
that's from the show but really that's
you scare coyotes off by yelling
they know that though yeah they do know
that they know that i didn't know that
until yesterday and i don't think it
works i don't think you should recommend
to people that if they're getting
attacked by coyotes that you just yell
pop up i don't know if the coyotes are
gonna go okay but here's what you're
doing i didn't know i was dealing with a
stigma male 1 so peeing it also is good
for deer so in ronan virginia it's not
good for dinner parties i don't
recommend you do that if you haven't it
was pretty much over it was over i was
still eating some zuziki we weren't on a
date no we weren't on a date nick was
there this is family
yeah that was i think he would have
known i think he was going to be anyway
i don't think he had to be no he would
have peed in here no but i don't think
you need to be yeah
yeah
and then he sees it i pee and then peace
and then it's like
you should you should do your own like
construction
why don't you do your wrong like because
you got your own style
she definitely has her own stuff that's
where he is yeah you should do your own
like that's the paper she wiped with
when she peed on the floor
you got to become a dog you know what i
mean like no you're the lead the outfit
so we can pause this
and that was after she peed outside and
then the link i just sent is the coyote
one and no rush so you you do it so dear
thinking about it so deer
so in in virginia many places hunters
leave food out so that the the deer it's
cheating so
my ring camera caught it
have people seen this before yes yeah
it's on my instagram
you look like the girl from ring
by the way new from new
marine so these are the two places they
come so that's it yeah
the ring camera just shit right there
look do you see it shitting and then i
go to where it shit see a piece of shit
yeah no i can't please yeah i know i i
get it
i get it well-played yeah
so i get what you're doing i get what
you're trying to do so then i'm getting
in with the animal world you have to
become because we are animals though
that's the mistake we made we totally
are i i started thinking oh
look at humans for leadership and i
looked at all these toxic bosses do it
wrong and then you go no you take the
lessons from the wolf pack and the
lessons from the herd they figured this
out thousands of years ago right just do
what they do so instead of going don't
be inside why are you peeing inside oh
you do you can't do that they don't
understand what you're saying you have
to speak their language right so when
you go in when you go to vietnam i don't
have no plans on that me either but yeah
i i went and i i went to see how long
bae and do operation smile the cleft
palate said and i got so freaked out by
seeing babies smoking on the street that
i had to go home um and so
but you just be
the animal you learn their language so
if you're gonna go to if i'm gonna go to
greeks greeks greece yeah i'm not going
to just yell english louder i'm from
amer i go
i have to learn something you have to
learn greek i just communicate with them
but it's all body language yeah
so
i'm trying to ingratiate are you saying
i should learn if i i would learn
vietnamese and or who am i what animals
am i
acting like in vietnam because you said
i go to bed no i'm saying when you talk
to vietnamese people they're they're
humans they're equals they're not
animals but we are animals you said we
are animals okay you said you gotta be
like yeah right okay so so
i'm gonna have so you're so you still
call cigarettes
you still call cigarettes fags do i
still come if i'm in england it's not a
big deal and you have a time machine
yeah well no they still do it over there
in england now they mean they make
can we get back to the dog
this is how we tease out the tension so
we uh i go upstairs yeah time flies with
you i i go upstairs that's why we need
to make a time machine yeah put the dog
upstairs mona the alpha and the puppy
are
playing
it all worked i i did all the rules of
the pack
i turn around because my omega daisy is
like scurrying to go into her place but
she sleeps on the floor because she's
lower in the pecking order and i'm
trying to film it this is my mistake
i'm i get distracted
well no i was also because i want to do
a puppy training video so i'm filming it
and then i turn around because i'm like
what if this door behind me is not open
that would give mona the opportunity to
if daisy can't get in and she scurries
around
moana's gonna get her so i turn around
to open the door
and by the time i turn
30 degrees back mona has already flown
off the bed
gets daisy by the neck and
thank god it was up against a wall so
i'm trying to get in between them and
it's
daisy's mouth is just in her all her
gels
and then
yeah so and then jana saves my life go
the stigma male came to the rescue
i heard you know what he the real
stigmas yeah don't take their sneakers
off till right before bed because you
never ever know what's gonna happen and
that's why i don't wear flip-flops
because you never know when shit's gonna
go down so this that's a man that's a
brooklyn new york trick you just always
got to be ready you never know you sleep
in your sneakers i sleep with my
sneakers yeah i sleep in my sneakers you
never know what's going to happen
rinsing i sprint so i hear muscle on his
body not a muscle on my bed just fat
flopping everywhere as i ran you could
just see good i told you all right yeah
great thank you
um i just hear a commotion upstairs i
don't know what's happening
you're down here oh yeah i was like all
the way down there i was like looking at
my phone and i hear just whitney
screaming and i hear bangs there was
just bangs on the wall and i go in there
and it was just two pit bulls
locked on each other it was like a real
bad fight
and then me and whitney broke him up we
broke up the fight we got
daisy and mona apart but there was blood
everywhere there's blood on my bed i
slept with it because i'm a stigma male
but there is blood on that bed you just
skipped like five good parts of the
story i don't know what else there is to
say there was blood there was a fight
was i yelling when you came in you said
oh yeah that part's good so i you know
you're supposed to pull the hind legs
when you know you don't you don't want
to put your hand in there this hand was
all in there whitney has no fear she's
in the animal kingdom there was two
pimples their jaws were locked and
whitney's hand i just saw whitney's hand
in there because i was thinking about
emily going if i because i almost lost a
thumb the last time this happened
my right thumb the thing that made us
evolve to be dominant species i don't
have a fucking right thumb i can't put
necklaces on i can't i can't zip zippers
i'm just like a invalid this is when i
was in the portland shows with renowned
hershberg uh helium portland i had a
fucking tourniquet on my
finger right i couldn't how do i
masturbate without my right thumb
and then
and that's how you use the thing but i
think about emily i like i thought about
emily and grace because i was like if i
lose a hand like we're the tours
canceled like i was just like i
we've worked too hard to get here so i
was trying to do a fist and i started
just wearing these rings yeah so mona
got me a couple times but it hit these
rings these are vintage native american
rings you're so lucky
i i did get lucky yeah but i i'm lucky
that you were staying with me so young
came immediately picked up the back legs
because that's the first thing you want
to do you want to get the back legs of
the one that is getting attacked because
if you do that
their head goes to the ground so then
the dog's attacking the head yeah
instead of the jugular so you just want
to you know so we were trying to pull
him apart and uh and then whitney goes
stick your finger in her ass
i meant my ass
and but i also said butthole yeah or
something yeah
and
i did take a moment to take that in even
though we were like in the throes
and it's also quite a challenge to kind
of locate the asshole like because
they're fighting once you do it's so
that's the thing the finger in the
asshole is funny to joke about
it's not possible really because unless
you have three people helping you and
one can you i can't really find it well
it's just it's just you know yeah it's
just too much movement and they were
really going at it and we got them apart
thank god we pulled them apart like
y'all like and then we did a lot of
heavy breathing
we were just like
because it was like intense it was an
intense dog fight what would have
happened if you weren't here
that's sad but yeah if i wasn't here i
think yeah unfortunately daisy would be
dead some do they wouldn't have stopped
they would not have stopped daisy would
be dead i'm a dog lover so it's tough
but yeah that that and i would i would
have an even weirder face than i have
now you might have got you might have
caught some collateral damage but
definitely they would not have stopped
they were locked in on each other yeah i
mean that fight was all out so then
daisy's bleeding
um they both got hit right so yeah
mona got hit on the head
and daisy her tooth like the
yeah i was yeah so her
daisies
so here's the good thing about these and
she had just lost 12 pounds which she
was when your dog is overweight you're
taking years off of his life her life or
his life
or their dogs identify i don't know how
they identify but um so because it puts
pressure on their especially small dogs
on their joints and so then they get
okay we can take that down um thank you
emily's not loving emily's not loving it
and so um i'm not loving that that's
just something i'm not loving a picture
of giannis so
i'm just loving it i have the same
reaction my podcast long days and then
so um
uh sorry this does make me a little
emotional but um we were there though no
we saved the day and they're fine so
they're we were lucky no i'm just saying
because they were bred to fight yes so
they were bred to have big jowls which
are designed so that they can't get to
the jugular so i just think about all
the dogs that you know and so she had
just lost 12 pounds uh which means she
had more skin so if i hadn't done the
right thing and made her lose weight
which was like i hate because i'm a
feeder i'm like i love you i love you
please know i love you you know but it
makes them fat and kills them so and no
feeding dogs bean beans peas or lentils
because that's what's fucking up their
hearts and i made that mistake and
because i was like we give dogs
vegetables so we don't kill cows they
need the taurine from grain and they
need fucking meat the beans peas and
lentils is giving dogs heart disease
which is why two pit bulls that are on
fucking sodalol and pmo abandoned for
their hearts so um don't don't listen to
influencers on instagram for your vet
care please yeah um
and so um and rogan had in his last
special i thought that
cats can't be vegan it was like a kid
someone had a vegan cat or something and
um
so daisy's got blood that's like viscous
like you know that blood that's like
mixed with something and i'm like is it
like is that like we didn't know where
the wound was because it was just blood
on her nose on her face but the blood i
thought it was like keep bubbling out of
his no her nose like it was like and i
was like oh god this is it like daisy i
was like mona got like her brain or
something and like it's a brain bleed
like i was just like this is it like
this is where i get to have a heroin
addiction and it just starts and it's
over and i'm just i'm just it's done
like i'm done
um if i'm why this dog got attacked
because i was fucking
not paying attention
um or trying to multitask when i was
supposed to when i because it was the
second i looked away from her flew her
ridge back fucking dna they used to herd
lions ridgebacks yeah no they're tough
you know the only motherfucker that can
beat a honey badger
ridge backs are tough the only one if
it's a
so they used to herd lines there's
videos of them hurting like five six
female lions
don't fuck with them yeah so and she's
like more she's pit too she's like and
then so she's got the protective of
babies because pits evolved to protect
babies they're they're the nannies so
they also evolved to what was the number
one thing that killed babies thousands
of years ago
the hyenas
maybe in africa yeah
rats
because rats would give bite them and
give them diseases so
that's why in the walls if they hear you
know english lords whatever maybe yeah
so
yeah well
sultan's yeah i was going to say
don't get me started
um on pit bulls need to be police dogs
this whole thing um but uh
so
then you're then your boyfriend comes
home so i just happened i made it i
finally made one good choice in life
and
he came home with like rubber gloves on
like i didn't even tell him i didn't
even tell him it happened yeah i didn't
give him
yeah i was just well he had an emergency
surgery he was supposed to be home at
eight so i'm just like updated when
you're gonna get home don't tell them we
clean them out with saline solution yeah
we clean daisies wounds yeah you did i
had antibiotics so i gave her two
antibiotics when you have a dog bite the
number one thing is the teeth are so um
have so many so much bacteria on them
yeah just antibiotics soon don't worry
the wounds you will not know which wound
is a problem because the superficial
ones are often deep and the biggest
mistake a lot of vets make is they try
to sew it up it sews in the infection
they abscess where was nick throughout
this whole thing hiding
yelling in the yelling around the yard
because we couldn't find the puppy oh we
were looking for the puppy and the puppy
yeah the puppy i go don't wait so you're
telling the ending this you're sorry i'm
jumping around is it because i know you
don't like to do that you're like you
stay you're you're blue you're spoiled
you're right spoiler yeah spoiler alert
yeah we're missing like two beats that
are gonna make that even better i'm
sorry it's okay we're rushing
um i did not waste 15 years of my life
learning how to make television
um
uh to not know how a story should be
told it's my only i'm jumping over no
it's good because we're trying to do
cliff's notes and that's our other
podcast right that's uh
so yeah we weren't going to i'm like
but but you're you're speeding me up
though and i'm slowing you down perfect
yeah ironically
um and so
i'm like yeah find the puppy
cause i go
it's downstairs getting eaten by a
coyote ran downstairs a coyote is now
killing the puppy
and then i went he's in the pool
yeah cause i was in a fire as a kid the
worst thing that could happen always
happened so i just go bam i would it
would never occur to me that the puppy
was just hiding out of the bed yeah
right and so then uh nick's running
around the yard i gotta find the right
camera footage because he i would go
what was happening because i was just
running around going dogs aren't fucking
worth it dogs aren't fucking worth it
this isn't fucking worth it i'm gonna
get birds dogs aren't fucking worth it
um and so
then uh he comes upstairs we can't find
the puppy and then we look to the right
and puppy was against the wall just like
the puppy almost had a look in his face
like what the fuck just happened
and the puppy just found like this
corner and was just like ran away it was
just hiding yeah that puppy's sweet it
it's he's gonna be big he's a big tough
dog but he's got a real sweet
disposition what do we think his name is
i like bob for bob saget i like bob for
bob sage our problem i of course emily
noticed i misspelled bob saget's name on
my caption last night i did too did you
do s-a-g-a-t no i'm not i'm not an
asshole oh i didn't do it on purpose i
was just rushed i did
s-a-g-e-l
because i tried to make a quote and i
just didn't i like it's the el it's like
i went to sagit right in quotes and i
just hit l but no the only reason is
because he was programmed my phone is
sagging forever so i just i you know
right
we now take a break in talking about
the break
they don't want to hear it anymore it's
they're breaking benton uh it now comes
the time where we stop talking about
important things to talk about benjamin
mentioned
benjamin's decor
yeah
article is a sponsor and you guys know
we love article and i have been
decorating you moved into a place i did
i have a degree in my place with article
and i love it because my favorite thing
about article is when people go walk
into my house they go do you live here
because they're so impressed tell us
everything about i've got my couch from
there i've gotten this beautiful like
pink marble crystal like table that have
these like gold settings it takes your
breath away article this
direct-to-consumer company combines the
curation of a boutique for
a
furniture store from sweden
a furniture store
a curation of a boutique furniture store
with the comfort and simplicity of
shopping online articles team of
designers focuses on beautifully crafted
pieces quality materials and durable
contributions
affordable shipping is available across
the usa and canada
it's free for all orders over 9.99
an article is offering our listeners
fifty dollars off your friends
your first purchase of a hundred dollars
or more go to article.com whitney and
this account will be automatically
applied at checkout that's article.com
whitney to get 50 off your first
purchase of a hundred dollars or more
thank you so much for shopping and i
know what you're thinking again you want
to say you want to say goodbye but to
that i say hello fresh fresh fresh fresh
fresh when you think whitney cummings
what do you think
fresh you know what i'm thinking
what
i'm thinking i if you had breast milk
would you cook with it
would you be like
creamer lover
is it considered dairy
i yeah if hello
made a breast milk farm fresh
pre-proportioned ingredient and involved
breast milk that was seasonal and
delivered right to my door the answer is
yes blueberry booby muffins like grocery
stores
overall
for what cancelled grocery stores you're
cancelled heard it here first bye
you abused your power i have to get a a
buggy or a cart whatever you guys call
them i'm sorry i get a card i have to
walk in i don't have to get covered i
have to pack the card up then i have to
go to self checkout i have to leave the
house
i know
no thank you trips to the grocery store
and count on hellofresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable that's
why it's america's number one meal kid
hella fresh delivers pre-portioned
ingredients to your door including farm
fresh produce that arrives within a week
so you get convenience without skimping
on the
quality do you know what that means that
means there's a farmer out there every
week growing vegetables just for you
it's he single
checkfarmersonly.com that's a different
ad skip the trip to the grocery store
your husband's not there
save the time don't wait in these long
holiday lines don't be a scrub ensure
you don't waste money on excess food
you're better than that hellofresh
offers the flexibility you need to
easily customize your order online or in
the app easily change your delivery day
food preferences and plan size or skip a
week whenever you need to you owe it to
yourself go to hellofresh.com good for
you 16 and use codegood4you16 for up to
16 free meals and three free gifts again
go to hellofresh.com good for you 16 and
use code good for you 16 for up to 16
free meals and three free gifts hello
fresh that's why it's america's number
one meal kit so emily is not a dog
person unless it looks like a panda
that's okay
what does that mean like a panda so did
it go pap like a small dot like a pancho
she's a panda person you like pandas
yeah will you come just explain it when
he's getting they could be they could be
a little mean so emily's done stand up
twice and one of her bits her opener was
so i'm not a dog person i don't get it
or like them
pause
and then she was i'm a panda person
because they just they know how to live
they just lay around and extinct
themselves
you can get a um
i don't you can get a dog paint from
china that looks like a panda and that's
my that's your that's the only kind of
dog i'd want but i'd still wanted to
wear shoes and learn how to use a
a bathroom and i would never let it walk
around outside and then get in my bed
with its bare feet because do you walk
around barefoot and then get in your bed
my dogs don't get on my bed yeah okay
all right right this is it this is it
yeah by the way this is why um all of us
have such shitty immune systems we don't
play in sandboxes anymore and we don't
let dirt now it's a good point yeah
i'm good also i have clean sheets though
and i still love my dog my dog sleeps in
a dog bed so nikki glazer's a bird
person i didn't get it
she was like i'm doing a rescue um to
help
rescue birds and i'm like then just open
the cage yeah right
so it's like cranes and i'm like okay
the oil spills and cranes i get that but
birds i'm like you can't attune to that
like they're i just do any of you guys
like human babies
that's emily emily likes a human that's
emily yeah so emily amanda knox was here
with her baby babies to me
are just i don't they're just not cooked
yet and i i think they've been they're
born too early we need they need like
help i just can't
i'm too rough and too
i can't only have something around me
that can hold its head up on its own
right because
i don't have time for you to like be
that weak
and there's a hole in their head like
their skull is not yeah it takes a
little while to help so if i can touch a
brain through a little piece of skin
like yeah the way i am with puppies
emily is with babies right do you have a
baby
oh she's too good for like she's every
she's
the super nanny that is like i'm the
most qualified to have a child but
because
i'm so not selfish i'm going to wait
till it's the perfect time and 40 is the
new 30 for women
bridget fedesy got pregnant naturally at
43. my mom had me at 43. yeah huge so
i'm i'm i'm a mess and your eyes aren't
that close together they're very close
together
cyclops cult where are you at
what is it blind stamos it's a special
needs statement
yeah um yeah we're definitely on
different ends of the greek spectrum
genetically i was wrong about birds so
as emily pointed educated me crows can
recognize faces yeah they hold grudges
they're bitches crows
well if you bitches if you feed them
they'll start bringing you
gifts and they're using tools so as
emily said
when you told me crows can do card
tricks well david blaine yeah i don't
buy it sent me a video
when uh where a crow
and i it's magic so what i think is they
made the cards have it smell like
something or right or
they just or the cards were rigged which
is fine
we love magic we love magic here we love
we love magic
um
so
the crow would go pick a card like out
of a deck i don't think i'm allowed to
say someone's tricks of magician's
tricks so let me not fuck this up let me
shut up let me shut my whole mouth this
is where i have to shut my yeah whatever
happened the crow picked the cards the
crow picked the card and knew what was
an ace a diamond or a heart right so
you know but crosstalk whatever you want
to believe
so crows are incredibly smart and they
emily knows how to say this we together
we will for the amount of time they've
been evolving they're further along in
their evolutionary journey than we are
in ours i don't know if i buy that okay
then emily will find the article and
crow's going so
hold on infowars.com so you're saying in
the future crows are going to be like in
spaceships yes
or not well we'll be the media will have
hit so we don't even need it i don't
know dude i don't see it happening i
don't think crows are going to out
peterson evolution but that's because
you're going extinct and you're just
kind of petulant about it because i'm a
white man we definitely already not you
but you're good you get to stay i'm
grandfathered we're in an evolutionary
pivot right and the people who are good
to the
the women the children yeah they stay
right you know right and the ones that
didn't abuse their privilege right you
stay we need you so i'm good
dude
white men and hold on let me first of
all i'm greek am i white is greek white
can i be less white i know all my
friends are like i'm armenian i'm like
two percent armenian
uh everyone's under 23 i mean half
native american like if that's what you
needed to get in college fine college is
a scam it was it was never fair i'm like
so pro the college admissions scandal is
ridiculous like it's never been it's not
as soon as there's sats which cause you
have to pay to take it's already a
fucking chance yeah and oh you didn't
get into usc oh bummer you don't have to
pay 80 000 in school loans for the rest
of your life like take the win yeah you
got a history degree which qualifies you
to be a history teacher and that was my
dad so really quick story about me and
then we'll do birds and then we'll pick
this up later if we need to so um
we're starting our own podcast so my dad
this is how my dad um used to make me
study for tests in order to be able to
watch 902.00 in melbourne's place i not
only had to know
um
the names of the chapters in each book
uh so he would quiz me spanish armada
spanish inquisition
lois and clark battle lois and clark
what'd i say lois no you said lois and
clark it's lewis and clark yeah but i
like lois too i liked him to think that
there was a chick there like with clark
there was a woman that was doing two
lovely dudes she didn't get names so
there was an inmate with them right
wasn't there an indian woman i'm sorry
native american can i tell you something
no one everyone talks about hitler no
one talks about laini reifenstahl who
actually made that all happen
who
the the filmmaker lenny rifenstahl
no she was the she made the propaganda
films
oh i thought that was uh
well i mean she was
like i guess doing all the editing
because editing was sewing right so she
did the shooting and editing because you
had to edit it together say what you
want he supported female filmmakers um i
don't know if it was sewing either i
don't know if editing was sewing it is
sewing it was pieces of clip yeah but
they would clip them but then you have
to sew them together tiny tiny string so
uh so okay so editors started as women
because it was sewing it was tiny finger
stuff it was women's stuff and not
anymore so i'll go with it yeah
they were all editors were women
not all but but it's strong why do you
have to go black and white it like it
doesn't it not or true
yeah so lenny reifensel uh helene bertha
emil lenny reifenstahl i'm sharon was a
german film director photographer and
actress known for her seminal role in
producing nazi propaganda a talented
swimmer and artist reef reifenstahl also
became interested in dancing during her
childhood taking lessons and performing
across europe that means she got
molested by some fucking polish dancing
teacher it's fine um
ravenstahl became one of the few women
in germany direct film during the
weimar period w w-e-i-m-a-r
in 1932 she decided to try directing her
own film dash blue lick the blue light
pretty natural to you that german um
i hope i have some like that's just the
good part yeah in the 1930s she directed
nazi propaganda films triumph do
williams oh that's a big one
olympia she directed that wow a woman
directed that nazis were very
progressive in some way
damaged her career and reputation after
she made her involvement in triumph de
willins however significantly damaged
her career and reputation hitler was in
close collaborations with roof and still
so the the rumors they were together
and uh i think he was i don't think he
was having much sex it was like epstein
and gillane and like she was she was
procuring like the math you know what i
mean it was like some fucked up
symbiotic
um
and so
uh
my dad would say you know korean word
you have to name the dates name the date
so let's just make up a thing
significant things happen make a weird
date 1376
significant thing number two uh
the year two bc
the year two bc what what like he would
he would quiz me so hard
nero's doing something yes some roman
guy so yeah and then now spanish
inquisition sandals were so that you
couldn't you could do it with your eyes
closed
and and
like golfers not only can i do it if
there's wind if there's someone yelling
can't do such so if i go to the test
what kind of golf course is that where
someone's yelling cunt you suck while
you're playing golf all of them is
gentlemen only ladies forbidden real is
golf the acronym actually gentlemen only
lately i just forgot to get kicked out
of the course if someone said cunt you
suck but can you answer my question what
is the question the word golf yes does
it stand for gentlemen only ladies
forbidden
i'm going to say yes that's the rumor
i'm not sure if that's what let's that
it's like a rumor but it's very the word
golf is not an acronym for anything
rather it derives linguistically from
the dutch word call for call of meaning
quite simply club it just sounds like
you read a jezebel article once and it
said that
i'm just saying if if i was in a
business that named it golf gentlemen
only lady forgiven ladies forgiven
ladies forgiven for being ladies
i would then go no it wasn't based on
anything i would just we'd go guys new
truth we change it now right right right
right right so
my dad would quiz me on the thing i knew
everything backwards and forwards
i i'm changing louis to lois because
there was some bitch that was making it
happen wait oregon trail
and then um
and then he put the book down
and then i have to watch my respect so
you got tiger mom's by your dad but then
he would look at the book and go
well how do we know the book is right
right you're going to memorize all this
right even if it's wrong to fucking
stick the landing
kerry strug with a smile on your face
broken ankle because he would say when
in columbus discover america
1492. uh 1492 whatever and then he would
sail the ocean blue and then he would go
well
he didn't discover it but lee farrison
discovered it when
but actually like he would tell me the
real history but you need to know this
for the test right you have to go take
the fake test right right so he gave you
the test he gave you the knowledge for
the test to pass the man's test but also
he he made you woke at the same time it
was funny it wasn't your dad sounds like
he was woke no but it wasn't woke he
just like goes
there's no way this is true because it's
all history's written by the winners
like this isn't what actually happened
but that's okay so it's like my whole
thing of like when people take their
dogs to get um
i almost said caramelized emily didn't
like that at all they have the korean
dog meat festival oh and they put
caramel on them no it was that was it
just a joke oh cause i missed so jokes
like
if you
are talking about something and then you
do like a freudian slip and it just
happens to kind of lean into the
horrible stereotype it
no but they do eat dogs over like dogs
are they do yeah they do eat dogs where
what
they do yeah i know you tell me about it
yeah no they eat them yeah i spend most
of my like off time well what are we
going to do about it that's the point
you have to give the dog if you're
saying we're going to be leaders we're
going to be leaders but like are we
going to fucking over there me and you
by the way i'm it's it's not if you
don't let me just tell you in the amount
of time you did that i could have just
okay so we're going to give the people
that do the dog meat farming uh
skills to do another job because they do
it to feed their kids and they don't
have a choice so the the the hunters in
africa podcasts
shit
i need to get into the asian market i
mean that is the natural next just send
them podcast equipment and said just
dude just do this talk about how so it
yeah what they they cut off the feet and
without killing it
it's brutal i know
but i hate it but they do respect their
elders and we eat pigs so they think
it's like a lot of people think it's
weird that we pigs not a black and white
world it's not the nazis were actually
very progressive with animal rights it's
a hard thing to as long as they can
dominate and control them those weren't
animals but they were very progressive
with animals
which suck because they did a lot of
other harvests they use but they also
use the animals to look like better
people holding a dog just makes you seem
like you're
so villains always have a fucking cat or
something to make them look psychopaths
no if i have animals around me they'll
think i'm better so villains always have
a kid look how he loves this dog he's
can't do that evil has a cat but yeah
the skin one i don't trust anyone that
doesn't have a dog right except
emily because she wants a panda dog and
we just haven't gotten again yeah but
this i think might be emily's animal so
i got birds wrong
no watch you're the one that's obsessed
with crows your natural inclination is
birds
because you know you know why because
you'll never have a heartbreak because
this bird's 22
and is gonna live to 70. it'll outlive
you you have to put in your will
now watch this this is a bird essie who
has a relationship with someone else i
have a relationship with that person
very close
at my farm it took me like 40 minutes to
get them on
essie on me
hi
watch looks at his mom
i want my mom i'm going to put my foot
out so that you you'll catch me because
i trust you watch
hi mom
[Music]
now i want to get to my mom i'm not
going to try to be
i'm not going to get off me bitch that
was that that's what that was i don't
trust you yeah i'm going to trust you
bitch watch boundary received going to
see his mom get back to your mama
i think we should i think she wants mo
she definitely wanted mom looked me in
the eye
hi
hi mom
yeah
it's a little freaky when you see birds
speak english
they're dinosaurs they recognize faces
he knew i was smart and so we tried to
do an arm thing where we just
transferred her from one arm to the
other thinking it was her and she was
like
they know
they have the intelligence of three to
four year old toddlers
and uh
you have to greet them differently so
i'm like hi essie and she goes no no you
have to greet her as whitney
and you need to just she needs to learn
your voice and get a code this is like
i'm like oh this is like a
baby
yeah is that not wild
they're diet they're they're dinosaurs
yeah it's that's a parrot right that was
that i think is a cockatiel we'd have to
look it up
i mean he was a cockatiel yeah we're
still fighting over whether it was a
hawk or a falcon that was definitely red
right here's a red tail hawk so we've
i've got a red tail
are you there must be a female thing
because we have two red tail hawks
aren't they s sigmas like they're
stigmas owls are usually in pairs so
i've got two owls a white one and a
brown one
very progressive interracial al couple
and they are colorblind but um and
that's i think animals are colorblind
they don't and they don't care what you
do for a living they don't care would
that fix a problem if we just like
started taking lessons at birth we just
made everyone colorblind
well now black people are like we
finally started getting ahead and now
now you want to get rid of now you want
to get rid of the colors that's it
that's my whole thing with bitcoin it's
like oh now that you're losing you want
to change the game we i just learned
regular money we all just learned
regular money right now you're gonna
change it just because you're losing
right i don't know if i like that do you
own any bitcoin no you have zero zero
are you worried about that i am because
i don't i don't like anything and i i'm
doing a big bitcoin convention next year
of course i'm gonna get it at some point
right to participate because it's gonna
revolutionize uh economies in africa
like the places it's needed like
argentina who the bank system is you
have a thousand dollars you wake up the
next morning and you just have no
dollars like so
i don't need it for me we don't need it
for us right but i think that it's going
to
revolutionize
um
uh it's going to give access to the
people who banks wouldn't give loans to
and you know and
hot take
the mafia can operate i've heard a lot
of mafia this week so today so feels
like a week but i've only been here for
12 years
but the mafia is their thing is we step
in where the government fails right and
the government is failing more than i've
ever seen in our life so i need the
mafia back the mafia needs to come deal
with the homeless thing they'll give all
those motherfuckers jobs at the meat
shops and the dry cleaners and like the
mafia i mean that there's that um great
documentary about the mafia in the 70s
and they were all at the subway i love
how bullish you are in the mafia right
now but but the new mafia is probably
going to be because the government's
over right it's it's collapsed right
who's going to step up the news is
broken right podcasters are stepping up
right it doesn't have to be italian
mafia right just like some type of mafia
so i i don't you would this is your area
of action this is my
expertise mine in stefano too but like
if the mafia can move in silence like
lasagna and not because they can't as
soon as it was like everything's being
tracked siri like mafia can't it has to
all be in person right so but there's an
alexa around your phone is off like we
have to go do do some bad stuff to the
mafia yeah i agree but the government
doesn't
the government doesn't so they do bad
stuff too well mainly they they because
they own ollie is anyone good
that's a that's a real it's not good
it's about
about you've seen succession
the show succession on hbo
that'll answer all of our questions it's
just it's not about good bad it's about
like can you do better than the person
that came before you just do better than
that person even if that if that person
before you was a murderer just murder
better and assume they had a reason that
it served their self-interest in the
interest of the pack at the time right
it's not okay today to just if someone
disagrees with you to shit at the time
it's what needed to happen right you
know what i mean and then but that can't
be used for all things the repression of
women do you know what it is right well
that one that did have to happen there's
a lot of good points because
take it as a compliment because women
were talking too much well they were too
effect i mean i'm writing this thing
about um
uh why so young girls so a friend of
mine has a five-year-old
and i was like playing with her
and
she is
a warrior like of like so my thing with
young girls i always go
try to take me to the ground just
anything you need to do wait a second
anything you need to do with little
children you're you want to you want to
fight them no i say
get i'm standing up straight yeah get me
to the floor you have a big advantage
though you're you're an adult but wait
but just wait there's weight classes for
a reason so she um do you call me fat i
know i'm a featherweight i'm not a
father you're actually in good shape but
i'm just saying if you let me finish my
story i would just interview you you'll
get all the answers you need just
playing devil's advocate
okay okay we got it so you're fighting a
kid no one's more of a devil's advocate
for myself than me yeah i got you okay
[Music]
remember this if you have a question if
you have a question you can raise your
hand that way
not that way you're yeah yours was you
gotta go really straight it was it was
really straight yeah would you
everybody's not sure about some of the
things which you need to be doing anyway
you can be stretching right now yoga so
uh there is a thin line between yoga and
hailing
[Laughter]
it's like a yaw it's a thin line between
a yawn and a hail by the way warrior one
is i mean it's yeah it's almost there i
don't love it i don't love it it's it's
an is an inch it's like a jaw
you have to be in really good shape to
make it that one yeah yeah i mean yeah
so man can't we no we can't do that
either we can't do a bald fist either
shit yeah it's close this is why we now
do air guns just always
so you're fighting the kid so no the kid
i just
so i'm beating up my friend's daughter
no so this was it so i go get me to the
ground because you can do it
and she goes
i see her thinking i love watching young
girls and boys like think and like
because it's just all their
epigenetic imprinting and answer right
so uh she looks at me and she runs out
of the room and brings back her dad and
goes to help me and i go no no we don't
ask the man for help you don't need his
help goodbye maybe she was scared of you
you were asking her to fight when a bird
did this
i wonder if i'm ever going to finish
this story no what she was doing she was
trying to she's trying to imprint on
this girl to be a strong woman that's
right i just don't know if these methods
are legal let me just finish is it legal
to fight it girl she's she she tried she
grabbed my ass i was i had no interest
in her
she was way too old for me she was five
i if i was a child a grown woman asked
me to fight i may get my dad i can't
even i'm just saying i see your point by
the way and here's the other thing
here's my mistake because i took a
shortcut it wasn't her dad it was like
another dad there okay so i should have
said that it doesn't matter did she get
you down so well so and also she's too
old for me because she can't give me the
baby blood she's too old for baby blood
so she can live you can live right um
what is that sweet spot for the blade be
blood i don't know it's only based on
there was a rumor going around that we
were getting facials that were from
circumcised baby dicks it's not true it
was placenta bovine placenta that people
were putting in cream
and um like epicurean has it kate
somerville it's like a placenta cream oh
and and then it turned into a baby yeah
these are from the same morons that it's
a game of telephone they eat their
placenta in l.a right and they make them
and put them in smoothies well dogs do
it yeah they also eat their own shit
they eat the placenta so that the
predators don't smell blood so that's
where it started the baby blood thing
yeah and there's more obviously also men
hate us
it's just
like we need new ways to call her ugly
and like we just don't like her right um
yeah someone came up to me in the
airport was like it was like three girls
they're like we heard you
put baby blood on your face to stay
young and i was like what are
three-year-olds doing on fucking girls
oh in an airport oh okay stick with me
alzheimer's stick with me yeah
and they're like we hear that you drink
baby blood or put it on your face and i
was like
then why are you talking to me right
yeah i mean you know you know i you know
i don't which is why you're talking to
me right so last thing they're just
being bitches so and then we're gonna go
we have gigi gorgeous and then we'll
pick this up later if we want we'll just
keep going we're gonna pick no the
second guest is here and she is a trans
woman and she's in charge she's in
charge so we are on the sidelines so she
um she's a piece so the girl jumps on me
she's crying at me she jump moves a
chair
next to me
jumps on my back right i'm i'm just
trying to get her to problem solve and
learn learn learn
and i go and in my plan this is my plan
my plan is to eventually just be like
like
to make her you know
and then she's like walking around me
it's like it's been like 10 minutes
she's behind me and i'm like oh fuck
she's behind me like like what's gonna
happen i'm waiting for like a monkey
like a flying monkey to come in
she goes between my legs
head and my knees
head butts me in the pussy
i'm so
stunned can we get this episode back
that i go down on my knees out of utter
shock yeah and then she jumps on me and
i'm down
just she was like
little girl knows how to problem solve i
was like
i was like this is i'm gonna pretend
she's doing it and just came in
it was and by the way she had um little
like um like pigtails that had the the
rubber bands that have balls on them you
know how kids girls do so there were
these two like me like plastic balls hit
me like in the pussy lips and and took
me down
that is a that was a fair fight so um
i'm gonna go say hi to gigi and you
close out the show
okay and do your um talk about the
sports show yeah
whitney has her methods on teaching
children
and raising dogs
you don't necessarily have to follow
them
um they're good point you know you can
use them as a road map you don't
necessarily have to follow them verbatim
if you want to teach a child how to
problem solve there's a lot of options
that are available through the education
system um that don't involve
getting head-butted in the pussy lips
or uh challenging a child to a fight you
don't have to really do that and if you
want to train your dog to pee
you don't necessarily have to go pee
first
outside
to show the dog what it's doing you can
just kind of take the dog to the p spot
and the dog
i think will relieve himself
but if you want to make it funner then
go ahead and take a pee with that dog
listen to my podcast put a camera on
janice's penis right now
because
hi gigi gorgeous hi this is
good how are you hi gigi nice to meet
you so good i was playing with your
pitbull
so cute come sit here i'm about to sit
down but this is just the end of his
podcast okay it was actually yeah it's
mine now
you had a good run yeah it's over it's
over it's over hi your replacement is
here she's here
i'm here yeah you know that the
natural next progression was now the
trans women just take over it's just
i mean it's it's our time it's your time
it's never not been our time it's all
the your strengths and my strengths plus
like
this is this is our leader now
just we're both passing the battalion
we're passing the baton to the next one
so we're just saying did you um log out
don't write elephants yeah well i i gave
a nice little speech i gave a disclaimer
i would say it's a disclaimer you know
what you can be i gave a disclaimer you
have a back-up plan you can be a mall
santa i okay you know well don't i don't
trust you santa's she's yeah well they
made me funny by blessing me yeah we
thank you
yes boy so um
we have backup plans like i'll be the
mall i'll be miss applause and we'll
work with them all absolutely and then i
need a photo of this guys this is really
cute okay hold on we gotta get frankie
in it yeah with like your dog come here
hold on
just skip oh here we go hi
wait are you in it yep yeah it's like a
family shot
it's cute chosen family uh-huh i'm
sending it
chosen by the way married to again
excuse me oh yes that's my hubby nice
yeah you're obsessed with that like
right but that's when it's like oh right
royalty so we'll talk about the podcast
but if there's a single getty just
wool
the family is huge so we will do a two
for the price of one pussy tightening if
we like whatever i need to do maybe a
classy yeah tell us when oh yeah speak
for myself
that wasn't a nightmare i don't you cut
two things out the end had the end
it was great
there are no ending there's no endings
there's just beginnings that was my
favorite podcast almost we've done for a
while oh i love that yeah but if you
hate did you cry if you hate it it's
probably good
oh if you hate it i feel like it's good
don't write elephants
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh
[Applause]
you